after the destruction of a month ago it
beggars belief that this could be
playing out again
in the rubble of the port another huge
blaze
this is a city genuinely traumatized by
the explosion last month
a skyline like this brought it all back
but more than that
naturally everyone wondered could
another explosion be about to come
and so they fled
for sure we are scared because it took
us back it's only been a month since the
explosion that destroyed baby
we saw the same thing happen again we
are definitely scared
and people are freaking out
[Music]
i had to take my wife and children out
of beirut because of this
since they're still living in fear after
what happened before
i'm forced to leave beirut for the
children and my wife
and just as they done weeks ago
firefighters rushed towards the blaze
their colleagues were among the dead
last month and so their battle to put
the fire out compounded surely by fear
as the flames and the smoke grew in
office blocks and in homes around the
city they opened windows to release
pressure in case there was another
explosion it was last month's shock wave
blowing in windows
which injured so many across the city
five hours after it started it was still
burning
helicopters overhead as the authorities
on the ground tried to establish
precisely what was on fire
people don't see this as a coincidence
it confirms what most here already know
that the site isn't safe it's not been
secured it was incompetence which caused
the first blast
and that remains by dusk this fire was
under control
but in a city already broken by the last
mark stone sky news